Peralta looks like an old friend of
yours is back in town who that guy Neil
that you punk with that sleepaway camp
uh Neil from camp was the best he could
pick up a milk carton with his butt
cheeks he was so funny you know who else
was funny
Bill Cosby everyone put on your parkas
cuz this week just got a whole lot more
chill out allow me to introduce Stevie
chillin shillin's he was my very first
partner and one of the all-time greats
takes one to know one man come I'm
Charles what uh hey what's up man I'm
Stevie
we heard Stevie and I were beat cops
together we called ourselves the beatsie
boys and yeah it was as cool as it
sounds so y'all would just stand around
like that Oh totally get it my first
partner was also pretty cool everyone
called us Chucky and the cute so I guess
we all had great partners that we've
completely moved on from because here's
died of old age he did anyway we should
motor Jake and I are staking out a bar
called the thirsty ox lot crime a lot of
danger but downtime for inside jokes
buuck some milk man would you like some
milk the kind could you look like Justin
oh please what's a friend fun he
remembers the funny that guy very funny
you know what's crazy
I've been tracking a dealer who just
took a job at the thirsty ox no crap we
should work the case together the
beatsie boys reunions or tag line boys
will always be boys no wait
some boys never change no wait boys two
men back two boys no wait boys no wait
okay it's ready still in town Benny
Ducati will know about it he owns the
restaurant they all eat at he knows
everything about everything good
hey when you were undercover did you
like have a mafia best friend much else
I'm just wondering I don't know I guess
I did a bunch of jobs with a guy named
Derek great great Garrett
sounds like a great guy Charles don't do
this to yourself right okay fine all
right so we're going to the restaurant
what's my cover I mean the mob ooh I've
got the perfect thing
a Sun Hat move you know just be yourself
a cop
Benny might think I'm a rat so I'll go
in and talk to him then you come in a
minute later with your badge out pick a
fight with me and punch me in the face
no I could never hurt you Jake well you
got hit me somewhere fine it'll be the
ball said no just hit me in the face
look if it's so hard imagine I'm
somebody you hate Derek I barely know
him fine Hart Bianca what do you know
about a guy named Derek Charles no the
dealer I'm looking for us Tom Ozerov i
arrested him a year ago in a
first-degree felony but he made a deal
and walked dudes a real lowlife yeah
we've seen that guy I said he looked
like a low-life remember that Jake is
pants were too tight yeah yeah hey you
know what else is too tight mm I was
working a case together again swerve
whoa yeah we say noice not swert look
I'm so sorry but I don't think there's
room for a third person on this case
Jake we should work it solo hang on now
boy let's not be hasty I mean Stevie's
been tracking those are off longer than
we have and three heads are better than
two
he's a kraut everybody knows that well
what about in the Lion King hmm when Jim
owned and purr boy become friends with
steamboat that's not the names
it's Simba Timon and Pumbaa but I
appreciate you trying it really is a
perfect analogy all right I'm in see if
it can work the case all right Charles
Boyle
welcome to the beatsie boys drive in a
car destination drug dealers bar that's
the Mike right over to Charles we forgot
Charles but we can't turn back - hey hey
buddy
I'm not gonna waste your time with some
lame excuse about why we left you behind
tonight just the truth Stevie and I were
taken hostage by an Armenian biker gang
and thrown on a cargo ship headed to
Asia but we're back now don't worry
about it
you can work the case without me I'm
busy bonding with my new desk mate Paul
hi my name is Paul Shh Oh nobody cares
Charles if I'm so sorry don't be mad
okay we need you to work this case with
us and you're way too good for Paul stop
trying to flatter me Jake face it I'm
not a beatsie boy all right well then
neither am i the beatsie boys are
finished if you're gonna be part of the
group we need a new name a name that
you're gonna come up with police pals
okay
decent cup with a couple options not
necessary that's the one okay let's go
besides if he does leave his room my new
partner will warn me new partner k13
it's a robot I can program between
outside Holt's door and if there's any
movement it'll send us an alert all
right I'm in but only because your robot
is so cool I don't know it's not that
cool I mean all he's doing is standing
guard I mean I could do that awesome if
you do that then k13 can come to the
party I am programmed to boogie my bot
no I'm going to the party people prefer
me over a robot I'm so sorry it's been
so hard to get down to South Carolina
between work and spending every free
minute on your case all right that's
enough touching you just pull the
touching time Amy I get a hundred
percent of the goodbye attention I'm 100
percent so Charles I gotta ask what's
going on with your hair well it turned
white from this dress but I didn't want
you to worry so I dyed it back to my
normal color with a splash of Itali do
you like it so how's my case going have
you found anything on Hawkins I've been
working it in here
you know whit no one's watching it
myself at night in the dark I guess I've
been mostly thinking about it we're
checking her 24/7 you know watching her
men combing her old files but she's done
a great job of covering her tracks we
will find something babe I swear don't
give up hope okay are they treating you
are you safe yeah I'm in protective
custody because everyone in gen-pop
hates cops and I really sure why
something about us locking them in cages
and letting the world pass them by so it
sounds like you're isolated and haven't
had any chance to make new friends
my cellmate caleb is okay just
member he's in prison no matter how
small the crime people don't change
don't deserve second chances
Charles relax I'm not gonna replace you
trust me all I've been thinking about is
when you guys are gonna get down here
and now you are and we can finally talk
there's again significant the yard we're
going into lockdown inmates line up no
no no no I have 50 more minutes I need
this back to your sales right now no
touching time when are we gonna sit in
the back because we are all here
together and we are all equals hey I've
got an idea why don't we listen to some
sweet stakeout jams who do you have the
satellite radio station sedan Rock
seriously why not just go straight for
the Toni Braxton while you're at it and
I'm gonna make for Toni who is this
joker Oh check it out
guy entering wait I know that did you
buy it from ozerov I mean something's
going down
I say we gear up and we bust in like we
did at Pacala Ristorante remember that's
how we do it Brooklyn yeah okay it
sounds pretty cool but Jake and I
already talked about how we'd play this
we had a pretty sweet combo about it
remember I think we should do
surveillance collect intel and build a
case sure so we all got stories pal
look we need information if we bust in
there and Ozerov doesn't have any drugs
or whole operation is blown but I know
this guy all right he never works out at
one place for long I guarantee you he
has drugs on him and if we don't get him
now we never will well too bad for you
because Jake agrees with me we're always
on the same page yes tolian actually
Charles I think Stevie's right you said
Paige I know but he knows this case and
I trust his gut but hey let's go catch a
bad guy together right gear up police
pals hey what is that there were PT boys
you didn't even tell him this is such a
surprise I haven't seen you since I
transferred here how's Amy she's great
we're married and she's a sergeant now
Wow yeah how's everything here same MO
same Oh guess who's here Herman Herman
always playing Yahtzee knew everybody's
name worship Satan did he he never
mentioned that it is exhausting well I'm
Charles I'm Jake's best friend Charles
he's serving three life sentences no
need to flex so Caleb we're trapped
attenzione a dingbats perchance a riddle
Shakespeare what has six thumbs and just
arrested a drug dealer these guys
Charles thumbs up I said six thumbs and
we're showing four starting to look like
fools all right man we'll check in with
Flint you do some research when we're
gonna celebrate tonight here's my only
requirement it has to be at your house
cuz I ain't got no money
okay how about my house are you doing
what I think Stevie's bad news what oh
come on Charles
know you've been acting weird about
Stevie all day I think you might be
jealous of course I'm jealous I was
never hiding that oh he's tall he's
funny
can pull off an earring he doesn't have
an earring but we both know you'd look
good in one oh my god what do you want
me to say Boyle I've been trying to
include you in this all day long and yes
I forgot you that one time but I made up
for it that's left you in the face
you're supposed to be my friend I'm an
adult man I can have two close friends
hell I can have three close friends you
wouldn't I would maybe I'll get in touch
with my friend James from college who
Reid who just looked me up online Brad
from Camp Stevie planted the drugs come
on I look in that dishwasher before him
and it was empty
Steve you planted those pills but you're
right he's the coolest you guys should
go get your ears pierced together invite
Brad it'll be swert it's swurt not smurt
so joke's on you damn I see
you